Mm-hm.
One second.
All right.
Great job generating
the last few reports.
Your boss was able to use
the data you prepared for
her to identify some problems with
how the company was being run.
And now business is booming.
In the short amount of time
you've been learning Ruby,
you've already added value at Toy City.
Keep it up.
She's got another project for
you though.
After reviewing your reports, your boss
has decided that the inventory system
needs to be redone from the ground up.
Now, she knows it's a pretty big task,
so all she's looking for
right now is a proof of concept.
Show her that you can use
your new object oriented
skills to get a prototype
up off the ground.
For this project you'll be creating
a way to keep track of inventory,
customer data, and transactions.
These are the same types of problems
you'll commonly be solving when working
on a larger scale web app.